Booya
hashtag release the Snyder cut is
trending and now that stars like gal
gadot and Ben Affleck are on board it's
time to figure out if we will finally
get to see Zack Snyder's cut of
jealously and what it might look like
right now on the catch up in May 2017
Justice League director Zack Snyder who
also directed Man of Steel and Batman V
Superman dawn of Justice stepped down
after the death of his daughter so
director Joss Whedon who directed a
couple of Avengers films from Marvel and
was reportedly working on a Batgirl
movie for Warner Brothers took over so
we didn't job was to cut the film's
runtime and lighten things up with some
humor after the poor reception of the
very dark Batman V Superman so that led
to rewrites reshoots and lots of cutting
and the result was Justice League as we
know it coming in at a rotten 40% on the
tomato meter with an audience score of
72 percent toss in a disappointing
global box office and Henry Cavill CGI'd
upper lip because he couldn't shave for
the reshoots and yeah I mean I think
I'll stop at CGI upper lip right after
the movie came out fans created an
online petition to release the Snyder
cut that gained nearly 200,000
signatures and while that sentiment has
stuck around the movement was reignited
recently when Jason Momoa reminded MTV
News that he's seen the Snyder cut so
that's what he's showing Apple TV plus
is about
and this past Sunday which was the
second anniversary of the film's release
gal gadot Ben Affleck and Ray Fisher who
all starred in Justice League tweeted
out the hashtag releases a Snyder and
then Zack Snyder retweeted their posts
do we think they were just all together
and we're like okay let's burn up the
internet right now who knows but it
worked
as far as what we know about the Snyder
cut along with it being way darker than
the one in the all saw it's rumored to
be three and a half hours long which is
an hour to have longer than the og one
and obviously contains a bunch of
additional scenes backstories and world
building elements and Snyder said that
cyborg was supposed to be the heart of
the movie but much of his backstory was
ultimately cut as where the hearts of
Zack Snyder fans are
the world and there's also a handful of
characters that wound up on the cutting
room floor like the villains Darkseid
and his master torturers assad scientist
ryan choi who becomes the atom barry
allen's love interest iris west and the
shape-shifting alien martian manhunter
on top of that Willem Dafoe reportedly
shot scenes that were cut though we
later met him in 2018 the Aquaman and
Jesse Eisenberg's Lex Luthor was
supposed to have more screen time aside
from is one post-credits appearance and
I'm realizing that this whole video is
just becoming one big tease shouldn't we
have a beat of our own so now that
you're justifiably frustrated that we
didn't get to see Snyder's intended
vision for Justice League the question
now is will we ever well it would
reportedly cost around 30 to 40 million
in post production costs to add in
things like special effects and
soundtrack and insider told The
Hollywood Reporter recently that there's
nothing in the work at the moment so his
Donnie Brasco would say forget about it
but there's still hope because gal and
Ben still have working relationships
with the studio and no doubt carries
some clout
plus we're entering the age of the
streaming wards you guys and what better
way for Warner Brothers to make an
impact with their new HBO max streaming
service than to drop to Snider cut I
mean even sad Ben Affleck would smile
about that maybe
so it is time it could get over to you
guys now do you have any interest in
seeing that Schneider cut and do you
think it'll ever come out let us know
all your thoughts in the comment section
and for more DC news head on over to
Ryan
tomatoes calm and good news our first
book rotten movies we love is out right
now it celebrates 101 movies that are
coming in Green's but definitely worth
checking out anyway
as always thanks for watching the
ketchup if you liked this episode and
you want to see more subscribe and click
that Bell icon I'm Mouse pres and I'll
see you guys next time
[Music]